british prime minister boris johnson has
announced plans to scrap the last
remaining coronavirus restrictions in
england speaking to parliament johnson
said the country was moving from a
strategy of government restrictions to
personal responsibility as it learns to
live with the virus among the biggest
changes starting this thursday people
with covet 19 will no longer be required
to self-isolate
and for more joining us from london is
our correspondent charlotte charleston
pill charlotte tell us more about prime
minister johnson's new coveted strategy
well this was the prime minister's
highly anticipated living with covert
plan and welcomed my benny within his
own party but of course for others
particularly those who are clinically
vulnerable this is a moment of concern
now to give you again that the two main
headlines out of the prime minister's
announcement today the first one you
mentioned that was that as of thursday
even those who test positive for covid
are no longer legally required to
isolate now the advice still will remain
that people should limit their contacts
remain at home there is no legal
requirement to isolate with covert the
other big announcement which is getting
a lot of attention here is the end of
free testing it will only be targeted at
the most vulnerable that is another
controversial decision but the prime
minister has stressed that this is not
the end of cobit it still poses a risk
and the fact that a royal highness the
queen tested positive just yesterday was
a stark reminder of that but he did
stress that now was the time to lift
those final legal restrictions he
pointed to the high level of vaccination
in the country he said some 71 percent
of adults in england have now been
boosted he pointed to the treatments we
now have the scientific knowledge and he
said the data that is emerging on case
numbers and crucially hospitalizations
as well
how are british health experts reacting
to johnson's plans
well as i'm sure you can imagine this is
a controversial decision and a lot of
scientific experts have been keen to
stress some of the pros some of the
reasons that this might be the right
time and of course the risks that are
involved as well scientific experts
pointing to the fact that we are now two
years into this virus there is this wall
as it's being called
of immunity that is uh in place but
good deal of concern as well while it's
known that the omicron variant which is
now the most dominant here uh is milder
it is that does not mean that it's not
still extremely dangerous particularly
for the most vulnerable so there are
those risks some of the prime minister's
fiercest critics as well might accuse
him of announcing this now as a way of
shoring up support within his own party
he has been under a lot of pressure
yesterday and as i said this is
something that will be politically quite
popular for him for his supporters but
for those who are clinically vulnerable
this is a very concerning time a lot of
people will be looking extremely closely
at the data and the effect that this has
on hospitalization numbers some
scientific experts saying that they
really need to see the data that's
driven this decision
charlotte chelsea pill in london many
thanks